you know spike lee recently did an
interview where he said that
civil wars are coming what did he say he
said that he said civil war is coming
trump trump's not going to leave civil
war is coming that's it you're just
straight he didn't did he explain like
what does he mean by that
that's it that's all he said and it was
really i think i can't remember who did
the interview i think it was like
vanity fair maybe they they were
interviewing him and they asked him uh
something like what do you think is
going to happen in november and he said
civil war
this is like the only thing that
leftists have at any any capacity to
actually criticize me
is that out of 5 832 videos now it's
more than that because that number was
from like last week i have like maybe
like
25 videos about civil war and they're
like ah we got him he's talking about
the atlantic article they wrote about
civil war coming it's like yes
there are a couple videos where i
directly you know ask the question like
when the a.g in oregon
sued the federal government because the
federal government was trying to enforce
the law
it's like when you have the states
challenging the federal government's
right to enforce its own laws
or like that's kind of weird and scary
and that's like
the way to describe it is if things
really escalate into full-on hot
conflict between factions
or joe biden and trump are like boxing
each other on the white house lawn to
like become president or something
then they'll claim that these things
were part of you know what started the
civil war or was the civil war
but now you have spike lee straight up
said it he was in he was being
interviewed by some
magazine or whatever and they asked him
like what's going on and he made some
comment about
being like nostradamus or something and
he said civil war is coming
like y'all better prepare because this
mf is not leaving the white house
something like that
and so yeah just more more talk from
spike lee and then
you add this to this story we have about
these uh these guys
in uh in michigan and i'm just kind of
like
oh i'm not surprised like is this the
first of
many attempts on politicians yeah
dude you you violate the constitution
brazenly while laughing at people when
you do it
don't be surprised when this kind of
thing happens now i'm grateful to the
fbi that they got stopped
do you remember what happened with her
like a few months back
there was a anti-lockdown protest and
the next day
she came out and she was like well now
basically i'm going to
create an even harsher lock down out of
spite i remember that
i was like whoa this is dude she's evil
yeah like legit evil so i say she's evil
in the truest sense of the word right
when a bunch of people in michigan were
freaking out because her
emergency powers are too extreme they
started signing petitions saying we want
we want a
like a referendum on taking her power
away and she said do not let them take
my power from me and then when the
supreme court of michigan ruled
you can't do this she said i'm going to
do it anyway yeah
talk about evil completely mad with
powers here's the problem off of it
why isn't the federal government
removing her that's what they're
supposed to do right
like maybe i'm wrong i don't know but
but if you have
so like a governor and their legislation
says you can't do this and she laughs
and does it anyway
shouldn't the feds then intervene and be
like this woman must be removed
because she's not letting anyone do
anything and i'll tell you what else
what are the cops doing now the ag has
said she will no longer enforce any of
gretchen whitmer's you know
edict so she's essentially just
sitting in a room crying and screaming
demanding a lockdown that no one's gonna
enforce
so she lost right but shouldn't she just
immediately like isn't
don't we have some kind of thing where
it's like if you were ordered not to do
something you do anyway like we get rid
of you
like you're no longer the governor or
like your call
yeah but that's like that requires an
actual vote she's not letting people
leave their houses
yeah i'm exaggerating a bit but you know
you lock everything down people can't
actually organize
so anyway man here's my point
if i said to you you know a year ago
there i think actually i'll tell you
this if i said to you a year ago
that i think we're we're dangerously
close to a civil war
and that within a year we're going to
see like race riots
people screaming and fighting and
smashing stuff and you're going to have
like armed groups going after
state leaders and politicians and these
like rioters are going to be smashing
people's homes y'all call me crazy
i'm pretty sure you did call it about a
year ago oh i did in our group chat
i'm pretty sure it was around halloween
last night and i can't remember
i don't want to name drop anybody but i
remember like yeah we had a group
there's like a group chat with like a
couple dozen people or something
journalists and personalities
and i'm like it's common here's what's
gonna happen and there's like a couple
of guys who are like that's so
dumb that'll never happen you don't
understand the security state and i'm
like
listen these guys who plotted this
what happens when you actually have
someone like gretchen whitmer or you
know wolf in pennsylvania who also got
ruled unconstitutional
and they're like we don't care we're you
know we are the democratic party
or like you know what happens when you
get that then what happens if bill barr
actually says we are in you know in
intervening to remove
a despotic governor who's in violation
of the law
what happens if they do this now what
happens i mean it's likely
unlikely because she's the victim in
this story but what happens if they
intervene right
and where this close to the election and
then the left says
it's a coup it's donald trump staging a
coup like then you're gonna get
government faction versus government
faction
this this right here should be one of
the biggest red flags there's a red
banner flying above everyone's house
right now
that civil war these people think
they people can people can only think in
real time for the most part
they don't think to the future they
don't prepare or plan
so when you see people marching around
in a residential neighborhood screaming
rabble rabble rabble
none most people don't even think like i
wonder what they'll do next that's
literally what i do i'm like man wow if
they're marching to the neighborhood
it's only a matter of time before they
start like attacking and threatening
people that wouldn't happen they did
that last night
well this is what i'm getting to the
first thing they did we see in portland
is they went to some guy's house
who had an american flag and screamed
and said take it down or we'll burn your
house down
the new york times covered that the next
thing they did was they went around
snatching the flags off the porches and
burning them
now in where is wauwatosa they went to
apartment buildings and homes and
started smashing up their windows
what happens if you try to defend
yourself ask the mccloskeys
ask that dude in wisconsin you will be
arrested you must let the mob burn your
house down
this story like last night was so sad
too it was an apartment building that
had four apartments
and three of the apartments like the
people just left they fled they knew
that there was bad stuff going on
so they they went to stay somewhere else
but one of the apartments had a 70 year
old woman in it she didn't have anywhere
to go
and so she was hiding in her bedroom
while they were smashing her windows
and she called her landlord and he went
over there and he found her and she was
like shaking and crying
and he brought her somewhere safe to her
sister's house i believe but but she was
a fascist so sad
a 70 year old woman but she's a fascist
no
they don't know what her politics are
you must be mistaken cassandra
antifa only attacks fascists i read it
in the washington post
they've won they're going to the suburbs
and they're doing it and then
and that's when conservatives said
mail-in voting is going to backfire on
you don't do it the democrats were like
donald trump said without evidence that
mail-in voting will be bad
guess what happens now democratic groups
are warning
all of their voters not to vote by mail
i kid you not axios publish a story
if they only actually engaged in good
faith they wouldn't constantly be wrong
all the time so they said
uh it was conservatives antifa is coming
to the suburbs they're talking about it
the new york times all these outlets
they're like
antifa is not coming to the suburbs and
now they're smashing up 70 year old
women's
windows threatening them and their
families and i know i know people in
chicago who are like they came to the
suburbs
it happened thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you